Iain Duncan Smith has denied quitting as
work in pension secretary because his
views on Europe are at odds with the
Prime Minister and the Chancellor it has
been suggested that his shock
resignation on Friday evening was
intended to cause maximum damage to the
party leadership ahead of the EU
referendum but he insists he resigned
because last week's budget was deeply
unfair
while Iain Duncan Smith is with our
political editor Faisal Islam in
Westminster thanks Martin let's go
straight to Ian Duncan Smith thank you
for coming in now clearly you've had
long-running concerns with the Treasury
over welfare but you cannot deny that at
least the timing of this is influenced
by Europe not at all this is absolutely
nothing to do with Europe I would not
need to do anything on Europe because I
actually have as much freedom as I like
I was actually one of the first to say
congratulations to the Prime Minister
for giving us that freedom and anyone
who's watched what I've had to say over
the last three weeks would know that I
have not been restricted in any way so
Europe has nothing to do with this and
if you don't mind me saying so that is a
deliberate attempt to put something out
there that tries to discredit me my
letter was very clear I did not mention
Europe in it for the very good reason
this is about my concern about the
Conservative government losing its
direction and actually hurting those who
are most vulnerable going going again
and again after savings from working age
welfare without looking at the broader
areas where we might be able to make
savings and broader reform and that is
what my passions been I came into
government for that reason I came in
having set up the Center for social
justice
I didn't want another job I just wanted
to do this to try and reform welfare so
that we actually help those most in need
to actually get back to work and to do
the kind of things that they're I expect
from my children and no doubt for yours
but that is a profound philosophical
attack on some of the basis of what this
government has done you've attacked the
welfare cap you've attacked the idea of
you're saying that austerity is
ideological a political thing rather
than an economic necessity some of this
stuff taught Jeremy Corbyn could say
yeah okay well let's just backtrack for
a second and give you the answer to this
first of all what I have said is in the
letter quite categorically there are
many things that I'm incredibly proud of
doing in
welfare reform package in the last six
years my concerns about this ARPA after
the election I stayed in because I felt
that as we were looking for more savings
I would be able to moderate some of
these and change them I went through a
lot of tough decisions last year when
tax credits which I was concerned about
were cut and then reinstated and then
Universal Credit had the raid on the
allowances which means it's like you'd
be less influential and getting people
back to work and then they went out to
the taper and I managed to fight that
off but I began to reach the conclusion
that I was more and more and sent
semi-detached in other words these
decisions were being taken almost in a
another place and that they were very
well they were being imposed and while
we had debates and rao's and then this
last bit linking this change which was
only meant to be on a consultation to a
budget was what I did not want he asked
for it not to happen we shouldn't have
done that consultation response until
after the budget said at which she got
linked and worse than that it was
actually briefed as a welfare saving to
pave the way for tax cuts I just found
that really wrong unfair and not the
right characterization of what we were
trying to do which is to a broader look
at disability benefits to be able to
ensure that people get what they need
using things like Social Care in the
community hospital payments and the PIP
which is a very good and settled benefit
to be very clear though you knew that
the PIP reform was coming in you knew it
was going to be scored in the budget and
you knew that it was going to be scored
at 1.3 billion pounds a year roughly you
knew that before the budgets we just we
very clear about this this consultation
started before the economy was seen to
get slightly worse this was about some
changes to pip that had happened as a
result of court cases and some of the
observation that that there needed to be
perhaps some review of that so this
consultation was about a number of
different things
should we make changes what should those
changes be and what were the range of
issues that we might change so we had
many responses to that my concern has
been all along that when that ended we
were almost immediately under pressure
because the economy apparently gone off
to actually get that consultation
response out the door in a front of the
budget so that then this could be part
of the welfare cap
I was concerned that we didn't need to
do at this particular stage we needed
more time over this then we are you're
saying the Chancellor alighted upon this
p IP reform as a revenue raiser because
he was trapped within his own welfare
cap no this was all about the welfare
cap being above the welfare cap needing
to say look we're not going to be over
welfare cap at the time of the budget
and my concern is only reporting on this
back at the Autumn Statement we don't
need to get this done now because we
need to take time this is very delicate
this area because we argued a lot
strongly about that now I lost that
argument about putting it out before the
budget but then I wanted it to be out
and detached from the budget and about
an ongoing consultation so you did not
know it was going to be scored in the
budget document now that we knew then
once you put the consultation out they
will of course take that in and do it
and you knew that it was a B scored at
1.3 billion each yeah I'm using all the
figures that are there my point this is
all I don't get I don't know well let me
just explain to you this is the problem
I over a period of about nine months I
have progressively reached the
conclusion that it is almost impossible
for me to meet that compromise point
which is you stay in government cuz you
think you can influence and change the
things that you need to change so that
your objective of helping the worst
often society can be met this became
very clear to me and was I was sitting
looking at the budget when I finally
realized what was in it I I reached the
conclusion and took me about 48 hours to
seriously think this through that really
I was better off out that I should make
these arguments about losing direction
about not getting a right and remember
you know I set up the Center for social
justice years ago I came into government
to try and reform and reform welfare to
help the worst off and what I'm finding
now is that direction of travel is being
lost and I just want to ensure that this
government of which you know I'm a huge
supporter generally I want them to get
back on track and I just felt i'm not
going to achieve that now because of
this narrowing of the base we can't keep
going after working age welfare and
leaving all the other areas unlooked at
that is my concern and I think it's
about about the ESA cuts you didn't
think this about the so kind they
actually didn't think that's about there
are lots of things that you do and
change that a part of reforms there are
all different reasons these are on
balance where you think these things
should fall my general view has since
the election progressed
civilly being that I'm more and more
concerned that a narrowing of our look
into constantly working age benefits as
we go forward he's going to skew this so
that we are no longer able to say that
we are about a one nation trying to
balance that delivery yes we have to get
the deficit down it's absolutely vital
but we cannot do it by doing it on such
a narrow base on working age welfare
that has been my concern now you can
disagree with me others out there can
disagree with me they can say this is
wrong but my motivation on this which is
how you started this interview I feel is
absolute I am passionate about social
justice whether you agree with my
policies or not that is my reason for
why I believe that I had to leave I
would rather leave and mount this case
outside than snipe from the sidelines
and brief as some people do I don't want
to do that I want to get out clean and
say look I have a different view and a
different way to do it I hope I can
influence the party to do that well come
back to the party strategy in a moment
but there was also another discussion at
cabinet was there not where you
disagreed with the turkey EU deal and
you wanted to be able to have the
freedom to do to say that that deal was
bad for security and now you do have the
freedom is that not a factor in your
resignation oh come on Faisal that is
the most puerile idea I've ever heard of
I already express my opinions about that
deal separate to this you know that and
therefore I don't know what the issue
here is I've already expressed that
that's out there publicly I wasn't
actually at the prime minister try and
say you shouldn't you shouldn't oppose
that there's a debate about whether or
not you can talk about under the terms
of the release of cabinet minister talk
about Europe whether you talk about
treaties but I've already made my
position clear about that I am not in
any way restrained on Europe that is the
point if I was restrained on Europe this
might have some logic it does not you
know I could have stayed in cabinet as
some of my colleagues have done and
they're still free to talk about Europe
the idea this is about Europe I'm afraid
you know I recognize this would happen
you know there'd be an attempt to try
and you know besmirched my it's not
about Europe well I came into government
I haven't spoken about Europe for ten
years I am in government because I care
about social justice I didn't have to
come back into government and I didn't
want any other job I have worked hard
over the last six years with our
coalition colleagues before
making compromises but I think the
direction of travel has been in the
right direction
my concern since the last election
staying in trying to make these changes
is that we are beginning to lose that
sense of direction and I want to reset
that and I reach the conclusion finally
and I am absolutely clear about this
that on balance it was better for me to
be outside now this is a big decision
for leaving government you know you have
all the protection of government I'm
putting all that on one side because I
care more about this now you can
disagree with me you can that you cannot
allege my motive is anything else than I
wrote in that letter I did not write
about Europe but only with my reputation
who doesn't who doesn't mind speaking
his mind would not have written about
Europe if he really thought it was about
one of your former ministers in your own
Department Russ Altman says that her
assessment was it was about Europe and
that you had expressed the view that you
cared more about Europe than you did
about welfare reform well I look I'm not
gonna get into personal comments from
her all I do is relay to you that all my
other ministers of all today said that
this essentially is not correct and that
these discussions and debates about
policy were held freely but we didn't
discuss Europe and I didn't make a habit
of discussing euro ministers because we
all have different opinions is your it
more important to you than welfare
reform no welfare reform is the number
one item it's what I have let this work
when I left government when I'd rather
when I left being leader I set up the
Center for social justice I've traveled
all over the country I've wanted to make
changes and when you take the decision
to come into government you have to
compromise I recognize that there lots
of times you might not have wanted to do
certain things but you think on the
wider sense you were getting more change
through universal credit the work
program things that were really getting
us going back to work we got more social
housing people in social housing back to
work than ever before since records
began these are all good things that
we've done as a result of welfare reform
but my concern since the election is we
are in danger I think of losing that
simple high ground of being a one nation
party and that is my personal view it is
what I care about I'll be caring about
it and long after the welfare wrong run
after the Europe debate takes place
whatever the outcome is I will still be
talking about welfare reform and so as
your party's strategy the notion that
you targets or you protect older voters
who have traditionally voted
conservative
in greater numbers and maybe the weight
of the welfare cuts hit the working-age
that hasn't just been an accident that's
been a political strategy of your party
driven from the Treasury Walmart are you
saying that that's wrong is it immoral
all I would say is I don't think we can
continue on the basis that the way you
search for these changes in welfare
comes from simply the working-age and my
view is that there is a broader range we
have a huge range of ring-fenced items
not just in my department and other
departments my sense about this is we
need to have a look about where we
honestly think the concept of fairness
lies and the fairness of the generations
you know being fair not just to take the
burden all on this generation we want to
we want to rebalance the economy and I
want to rebalance society and I think
you can only do that if you attack this
on a wider front and make sure that you
are fair throughout that so my motives
are very clear and I want to return to
this because they are attempting to be
impugned by some people who would want
to have it that way and I simply say to
you I care about one thing and one thing
only in my political life I came in I
served in the Army and I've come into
politics because I care about Britain
and the British people and I do not
believe that I would make any decision
that I did not think was in the best
interest of the British people that is
how I've lived my whole political life
and that is why on Friday I chose to
leave the government and to argue fairly
outside about changing this strategy did
George Osborne's
decisions both on imposing the welfare
cap reducing the welfare cap back last
July the tax credit you turn an hour
I mean he's missed his too big a while
you turns on his two biggest fiscal
measures in two successive budgets where
do you think his leadership ambitions
lie now
look I'm not generally interested at all
believe it or not in individuals or
their prospects or whatever I'm attorney
in one thing and that is getting this
government this government that I have
supported and continues to support on to
the right track with regards to social
reform and welfare reform rebalancing
society alongside rebalancing the
economy there's two things go hand in
glove his mr.anand done a good job in
terms of his but I think his record over
the last few years speaks for itself in
the sense that we've actually driven the
deficit down and their issues but my
concern is that in narrowing that
look for the deficit we are in danger
now of actually being seen as unfair and
being far too hard on working age people
and that's what I've argued and this is
why I felt that the issues the final
straw from here was this issue
surrounding this narrowing of the look
at disability benefits and I just felt
that was no longer your letter was
clearly aimed at the Chancellor
mentioned to Chancellor his favorite
phrase you know it was it reminded many
people of the Geoffrey Howe moment in in
the comments all those years ago well
it's not aimed at anybody it's aimed at
a concept and so when I talked about
Treasury which is correct I do I talked
about there being an imbalance in the
way that they look at these things but
you know this is an argument to debate
and I hope that the people that are
running this the prime minister the
Chancellor and others they listen to
this and they do think about this and
they make those modifications and change
they change the welfare cap they change
the concentration of cuts on unworthily
rebalancing which took a lot to pensions
well all these point I think should
generally be looked at in a sense that
what are we saying are we going to try
and do this solely off the back of
working-age people and all I'm saying is
I resigned on Friday because I felt
unbalanced I could not any longer
influence that debate inside and I
wanted to outside I'm still back to e
secure forms that we've changed and made
those reforms are all about actually
getting more people into housing and to
make sure that those problems that we
face through high and rising housing
benefit are all dealt with but at the
same time doing it with huge support
financially for local authorities which
I argued for we've got much more money
I'm simply saying now that after all of
that we have to be very careful there is
a limit to a degree how far you can go I
feel that we have reached that with
regards to working age benefits and I
want us to broaden that look and to make
sure we put reform at the heart of it
not slashing back on things like
universal credit but actually
recognizing if properly implemented they
will save billions further down the road
that's how you save money you change
lives by reform and you save money we've
just got our statement in from number 10
responding to your previous comments
with authorities Ian Duncan Smith go but
we are one nation government determined
to continue helping everyone in our
society have more security an
opportunity including the most
disadvantaged do you think this
government is living up to its
self-proclaimed one nation ideals
I wanted to I want to now think about it
well I think there's a danger that it is
drifting from that through its policy
implementation and I wanted to change
that it's not across the board it's
particularly in my area of welfare and
as I said earlier on consistently going
after working age welfare I feel you
know has great limits and the reality is
they're already saved in year from the
2010 expenditure forecast we will say by
1920 in that year some thirty three
billion pounds I think really we
shouldn't keep dipping our bucket into
that well because that well is about
people with real difficulty and I want
to see us broaden it out will you make a
personal statement explaining your Asian
made rid my letter I've made my comments
to all of you all I would say to anybody
you could disagree with me you can
disagree with my policy you can disagree
with my ideas but I am genuine in my
real care and concern about working aged
people and I want to get the balance
right I want us to be that one nation
party I want us to be that one nation
government and I really care
passionately that we make sure that
social justice lies at the heart of all
of our policies that is all I'm after
that is what I want to do I feel I can
do it better outside than I can in
you'll be devoting your time to vote
leave now for the next three months
presume I'm going to devote my time to
reforming welfare I have my views on
Europe that those will be secondary
thank you very much for your time mr.
Duncan Smith Martin
there we go an interview with the
recently resigned work in pensions
secretary that the story that's rockin
Westminster this weekend